all right Jessica is with us in Michigan
hi Jessica how are you I'm great how are
you Dave better than I deserve what's up
okay so don't yell at me but I'm
wondering if it's ever okay to focus on
paying off our mortgage ahead of a
wonderful federal loan student loan
no because denial is a river in Egypt I
know he's got 72 months and on the
10-year public service loan forgiveness
you apparently have not been doing any
reading about that have you I try not to
I'm trying to be dumb about it yeah
that's that's working for other people
too yeah 32,000 people have applied for
it 94 have been granted now it's
relatively new though right that it
smells just now reaching the peak of
just reaching the 10,000 it's just not
reaching the 10-year and 32,000 people
have reached the 10-year who had your
plan ninety three of them got it yeah
it's the greatest American scam in
history and everybody's standing around
watching it happen yeah yeah it's
unbelievable so how much is your student
loan debt that you think you're finally
going to wander out of if you don't pay
it it's my husband's and it's 38,000 oh
my lord
what do y'all make roughly sixty four
years right and watch have you paid off
so far it is an income based no no your
total debt that didn't you tell me
you've been paying off debts yes yes we
how much of you paid off in debts um
including credit cards probably about
forty thousand kind of like the amount
of your student loans so what is how
long take you do that we actually were
blessed with a $23,000 and he written so
that took a really good sizable chunk
off with that how long did it take with
that we've been really hurt at it from
here a year so in one year you paid
20 grand and you got 23 grand to go with
it right yes and so could you
average 20 a year that'd be two years
you'll be done with a student loan this
is true yes get it but the house is only
64 and it's a terrible terrible moment
it's a terrible terrible what mortgage
mortgage like it's FHA it's got PMI it's
terrible what do you owe on the house I
mean what is the house worth I'm sorry
the house is worth about 70 and we owe
about 64 okay
no I pass the student loan in two years
and then if you want to keep added you
pay off your house in three years so
five years from now both of them are
gone Terral 20 a year divided into the
numbers you gave me yeah did I do
something wrong
no no that sounds about right
cool get after it kiddo get after it you
cannot fix this by avoiding it being in
denial in your work you got to go in
attack mode
it feels like it's huge the other 40
that you paid off felt like it was you
June as soon as you started it God sent
you a $23,000 bonus check from an
inheritance and you already were
knocking on it knocking on it knocking
on it knocking on it you've proven to
yourself and to me you can reduce debt
at the rate of $20,000 a year that means
38 thousand our student loan is gone in
two years and a sixty four thousand
dollar mortgage is gone in three more
tadaa and you're not that old well done
call me back and we'll do it debt-free
scream together